en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos con el más reciente
lanzamiento y futuro plan de la nasa que
podría convertirse en un hito primero
recordemos que en julio pasado un
asteroide del tamaño de la gran pirámide
de giza pasó cerca de la tierra lo que
causó inquietud sobre si podría afectar
nuestro planeta pero por fortuna no
ocurrió en su mayoría este tipo de
cuerpos celestes de gran tamaño ya son
monitoreados de cerca por la nasa pero
ahora en un importante avance salió de
la tierra la misión d'art que busca que
por primera vez una nave espacial se
choque directamente contra un asteroide
para que redireccione su curso
puntualmente la nave viaja hacia un
sistema de dos asteroides llamado
dídimos que en griego significa gemelos
y está compuesto por un gran asteroide
denominado vivimos y otro más pequeño
que el orbita llamado de morphos
justamente ese cuerpo más pequeño es el
que buscará impactar la misión para
registrar en fotos y videos todo lo que
ocurra la nave de arte está equipada con
un pequeño satélite desarrollado por la
agencia espacial italiana que se
desplegará antes
vamos a impactar en este cuerpo que
asemeja el tamaño de un estadio algo así
como un asteroide del tamaño de un
estadio de fútbol que está en la órbita
de un cuerpo que es de una dimensión
cinco veces mayor
veremos que sólo con cambiar la órbita y
medir ese cambio podremos conocer la
cantidad más importante que es cuánto de
nuestro impulso proporcionado se
impartió a ese pequeño cuerpo que por
supuesto en una situación de peligro es
la cuestión más importante cuánto se
necesita para sacar una roca del camino
dado su tamaño y velocidad
efe nets ex ayer en la prueba de
redireccionamiento de asteroide doble o
dar por sus siglas en inglés contempla
un viaje de 10 meses a unos 11 millones
de kilómetros de la tierra donde se
prevé estará el sistema vivimos en el
momento estimado para el impacto que se
producirá una velocidad de 66 kilómetros
por segundo lo suficientemente alta para
el objetivo planeado
que se necesita para desviar un
asteroide
[Música]
un sistema de propulsión llegar muy
cerca de él y un sistema fantástico de
guía y navegación
porque estás viajando tan rápido y el
asteroide viaja tan rápido hacia ti que
debes impactar lo completamente bien
es un objetivo pequeño aunque sea del
tamaño de una pirámide es de una
dimensión menor en la inmensidad del
espacio
[Música]
space los expertos explican que la
misión podría convertirse en una
verdadera hazaña si llega a ser exitosa
dada la alta posibilidad de fracaso no
obstante si se logra es la prueba más
adecuada para que la nasa examiné si
este método y esta tecnología son
viables para defender a nuestro planeta
de futuros asteroides que sí representen
una verdadera amenaza cabe resaltar que
el sistema vivimos está lo
suficientemente lejos de la tierra por
lo que no es considerado peligroso
y si estuviera viajando hacia la tierra
tenemos algo de conocimiento por nuestra
historia la extinción de los dinosaurios
y todo eso que nos dice que los grandes
asteroides se pueden causar eventos a
escala de extinción pero son asteroides
de tamaños kilométricos sabemos dónde
están todos esos cuerpos y ninguno de
ellos representan peligro en los
próximos 100 años o más así que la
amenaza viene con asteroides de entre 10
y algunos cientos de metros ese es el
tipo de cuerpo de esta misión así que es
la dimensión adecuada para lo que
estamos probando
en la oscura
first bit just in game dejamos atrás el
espacio para hablar de kobe 19 porque
actualmente varios laboratorios están
probando spray nasal es contra el virus
hace unas semanas hablábamos de la
vacuna nasal que prueban oxford y
astrazéneca otras compañías trabajan en
medicamentos que en lugar de funcionar
como vacuna buscan ser una especie de
profiláctico o barrera para evitar que
haya contagio del virus vamos entonces a
la universidad queen mary de londres
donde los investigadores llevan más de
un año probando independientemente una
solución por la biotecnológica rafael
lapse justamente es un aerosol nasal que
busca prevenir el contagio
y para que el virus entre en una célula
necesita experimentar ciertas reacciones
químicas muy específicas
nosotros hemos sido capaces de encontrar
una manera de manipular esas reacciones
químicas y con ello detener la entrada
del virus lo que es fundamental es
que no importa que se pase a lo hemos
probado con todas las variantes de
preocupación todas las mutaciones de
preocupación y tiene la misma eficacia
porque es una solución de base clínica y
paste
hasta el momento la compañía ha probado
el aerosol llamado foxwell en 648
trabajadores de la salud en india
durante el pico que vivió este país
entre abril y julio por la variante
delta el efecto del fármaco fue
estudiado en medio de un ensayo clínico
privado y con esos resultados notaron
que suelo un 13,1 por ciento de quienes
recibieron el spray se contagiaron
frente a casi un 35 por ciento de
personas que estaban recibiendo un
placebo
y finalizamos en la ciudad iraquí de
mosúl donde el restaurante white box
estaba apostando por la tecnología para
atraer clientes por ello son robots
quienes le dan la bienvenida a los
clientes y les llevan su pedido hasta la
mesa la programación y el sistema
utilizado en el restaurante fue
implementado por un grupo de jóvenes del
departamento de mecatrónica de la
universidad de mosúl que crearon este
programa y configuraron el servidor del
lugar así llegamos al final de este
espacio a ustedes gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con nosotros que
hay más en france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]